All right, Tom.
Good to see you.
Let me get this straight.
Extreme pumpkin carving
is pumpkin carving using,
basically, machinery
that could kill somebody.
Is that right?
That's basically it.
And this is to get the job
done quickly, more efficiently.
Is that right?
That's right.
'Cause I'm lazy.
Okay, you're lazy.
Well, no joke, I did a pumpkin
for my daughter last night.
It took about two and
half hours to carve it up.
I was bruised and beaten at the end.
So, this is definitely the way to go.
Is that right?
Yeah, you can't let the pumpkins win.
You gotta get to 'em.
Can't let the pumpkins win.
(audience laughs)
That's a great motto for Halloween.
Those bastards have to die.
All right, why don't you start us off?
Tell us, what's the first thing to do?
Well, the first thing is to
take the top off the pumpkin,
so I use this thing, a reciprocator.
I see that you're wearing
safety equipment and I am not.
So, I should probably put
on these goggles right here.
Is that correct?
That's probably a good idea, yeah.
And you're using a reciprocating saw?
Yep.
So, I jab it in there like this.
Pull the trigger.
(machine whirs)
Okay, I don't even see
what saw that is over here.
I don't even know how to do that.
It's this one here?
I don't even know how to turn it on.
Thumb on that one.
I'm so scared.
Oh, there we go, right?
Like that?
Just squeeze it.
And then you just put this in here?
And then just make a?
Okay, that's a mess.
All right, so once you take the top.
This is much easier than
what I did last night,
and it's making a lot
more noise which is cool.
Would you recommend for people
to do this in there house?
Like, with kids around?
[Tom] Maybe outdoors.
(Conan grunts)
Here we go, all right.
There.
Good enough.
(audience laughs)
Okay, so then what?
Another tool I use is a
drill for doing, like,
nostril and things like that.
What does that do?
Just making holes.
There you go.
You got that one.
(drill whirs)
(audience laughs)
Use mine.
And by the way, there's a kind of,
it's exciting to do that.
It feels good.
Yeah, you're winning!
You're winning!
The pumpkin is like, "No, no!"
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah!"
Spank it!
Well, don't get crazy.
That's just sexual.
All right, let's go.
Another tool I use is this thing.
What is that?
What does that do?
I call it a pumpkin gooper.
I made you one.
Check yours out.
Oh my.
Oh, that's sweet.
Look at my pumpkin gooper right there.
It looks like his head.
[Conan] You see that?
Yeah, it's got a little.
And that goes in there and just.
You whip it around like that.
Give it a try.
So, this is what takes the longest time,
is scooping the goop out
of the empty pumpkin.
So, you're saying you put this.
(audience laughs)
That's pretty good.
You have to hold me while I do it.
(machine whirs)
(audience groans)
Can't let the pumpkins win.
You can't let the pumpkins win.
This is America after all.
Okay.
Wanna do one more?
I wanna do a lot more!
All right, let's grab that
pumpkin over there on the edge.
Okay, this one here.
We're gonna use a chainsaw.
A chainsaw?
Yeah.
I never used a chainsaw before.
Well, that'll go well.
In my life.
(audience laughs)
You could probably tell just
by how I've handled things so far.
The chainsaw's right over here.
It's the thing with the chain on it.
Thanks, pal.
(audience laughs)
Thanks for making me look even wussier.
There ya go.
Whoa, what are we doing with this?
Just take a chunk off of this side.
Off this side?
Like this.
(chainsaw whirs)
(audience laughs)
Why did mine?
Why did mine take so
much longer than yours?
I picked a good one.
I finished and you were reading a book.
And then, we made, like,
Siamese twins out of that.
See?
(audience applauds)
(Conan grunts)
This one just had a lobotomy.
(audience laughs)
Huh?
You ready for the big stuff?
Oh my God, what is that?
Tell me what that is?
Well, I read that the world record
for carving a pumpkin is,
like, 30 seconds or something.
And I said I can do it in
under a minute if I make this.
So, I made you one too right there.
Could you demonstrate
this and then I'll try.
What is this thing called?
I call it the pumpkin thumper.
So, you take a pumpkin like this.
Yeah, hold on.
Let me get out there.
I'm slipping on pumpkin
intestine over here.
And then you take this thing.
Yeah?
And you whack it.
Like that.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Right here?
Like that?
Okay.
You know how to split wood, right?
Yeah, I split wood all the time!
What are ya talking about?
I split wood yesterday!
With the thing that has the chain on it!
(audience laughs)
Okay.
(Conan groans)
That was too hard.
Yeah, too much muscle.
(Conan grunts)
Okay, that was too much.
There ya go.
Try again.
Right here?
Okay.
You gotta get really worked up into a rage
when you do this, I think.
Son of a bitch!
(audience cheers)
(Conan grunts)
Ready?
On three.
One, two, three.
(Conan grunts)
Oh, that feels so good!
(audience laughs)
Okay, I'm having a small series
of heart attacks right now.
(audience laughs)
The book is "Extreme Pumpkin Two."
It's in stores now.
You're a good man.
Tom Nardone, thank you very much.